bonsoir docteur l'espérance vous avez dû
évacuer avec vos quatre enfants pendant
que vous êtes médecin de garde c'était
une situation j'imagine assez stressante
pour toute la famille
oui bonsoir madame Dussault
effectivement ce matin alors que j'étais
en train d'opérer là au bloc opératoire
on a vu le point de 13 de la ville de
cette île à 9h30 où on a appris qu'on
devait évacuer le secteur qui s'appelle
le secteur des plages en fait il y a
d'autres secteurs tout ce qui est à
l'est de la ville de cette île du
évacuer on avait jusqu'à 16h le pour
évacuer la route 138 est complètement
fermée on a plus accès du tout au
quartier là de nos maisons et donc
effectivement ça a été une bonne journée
bonne journée en même temps parlez-nous
de la situation de cette évacuation là à
l'hôpital de cette île et des soins que
vous pouvez encore prodiguer parce qu'à
un moment où on se parle vous êtes de
garde s'il y avait une urgence comment
les choses se passeraient-elles
donc actuellement on a eu une réunion
d'urgence le vers 15h30 pour nous
expliquer un peu comment ça allait
fonctionner donc tous les patients
hospitalisés qui étaient médicalement
transférables vont être transférés dans
le courant de la soirée soit vers Québec
vers Montréal ou vers Chicoutimi par
avion ce qui laisse
l'hospitalisation le pratiquement vide à
l'hôpital ascétique l'objectif étant si
jamais demain les avions peuvent pas
atterrir ou décoller à l'hôpital de
cette île qu'on soit pas pardon à
l'aéroport de cette île qu'on n'est pas
plusieurs patients en transférer en
catastrophe donc pas de manière
préventive les patients ont été
transférés ce soir tout ce qui est les
patients du CHSLD vont être transférés
par voie routière soit vers Port
quartier ou vers Baie-Comeau et tous les
patients qui auraient à consulter par
exemple en urgence mais qui viennent de
l'Est là du pont de sheldray qui est
bloqué donc il le Nord ferment tout ça
c'est patient là vont être transférés
directement vers Baie-Comeau alors que
normalement de service pour tout ce qui
est la base goodnables en savant et tout
ça c'était cette île là ils vont dévier
directement vers Baie-Comeau pour
l'investigation voir le pour un
transfert éventuel vers les grands
salles s'il y a besoin de plus et sur
place à cette île y a-t-il les médecins
comme vous chirurgène dans l'école
d'urgence je sais pas où un accident de
tout il faut faire une chirurgie un
accouchement enfin est-ce que tout reste
en place quand même toutes les patientes
vont pouvoir accoucher selon les normes
habituels vont pouvoir faire leur séjour
à l'hôpital 24-48 heures comme ils font
habituellement les césariennes vont
avoir lieu il y a personne que
d'inquiétude avant de ce côté-là toutes
les urgences chirurgicales aussi les
urgences médicales l'urgence de cette
île fonctionne vraiment normalement le
bloc opératoire est ouvert il y a aucun
changement à l'heure actuelle de ce
côté-là c'est vraiment une opération
d'envergure le déplacer des dizaines et
des dizaines de patients que ce soit à
l'hôpital en CHSLD qu'est-ce qui vous
aide à faire ça parce qu'on a évoqué
peut-être l'armée à partir de demain
mais qui fait ça
sincèrement que je n'ai pas j'ai pas
d'idée vraiment le qui c'est occupé de
ça ça a été fait de façon accessiblement
fluide de de mon point de vue mais
évidemment je suis pas au sein de
l'organisation là c'est vraiment tout le
personnel la direction les
coordonnateurs tout seuls qui ont géré
ça nous on devait identifier les
patients qui avaient potentiellement
congé d'ici 24 heures puis pour éviter
des transferts si possible c'est notre
rôle au niveau médical s'assurer que les
dossiers étaient bien monté pour les
transferts et tout ça mais là tout
l'aspect logestion et coordination
c'était c'était hors de mes mains avec
ce qu'on vous entendez depuis le début
le caractère imprévisible de l'évolution
des incendies de ces deux feux qui selon
certaines hypothèses pourraient se
rejoindre est-ce que vous avez confiance
vous êtes pas une experte en incendie ni
en forêt c'est pour ça que je pose la
question mais est-ce que comme citoyenne
vous craignez ou pas que ça se rentre
jusqu'au centre-ville
évidemment la crainte est là mais à date
je pense que les choses ont été faites
vraiment dans les règles de l'art
on était évacué très rapidement en ce
moment j'ai un magnifique coucher de
soleil sur la vie de cette île le ciel
est bleu on n'a pas l'impression d'être
dans un grand nuage de fumée et on sent
pas du tout dans une zone sinistrée
maintenant on fait confiance aux gens
qui ont décidé de nous évacuer et si la
ville est en danger on a confiance aussi
que les décisions vont être prises puis
on va suivre les consignes à ce moment
avez-vous pu observer de l'inquiétude
ou d'autres sentiments chez des chez
d'autres citoyens qui devaient être
évacués
ah c'est sûr que j'ai plusieurs
connaissances qui ont perdu leur chalet
depuis 24 heures
menacé dans les prochaines 48 heures ça
fait partie malheureusement des éléments
qu'on pourra déplorer la suite à ces
événements-là mais pour l'instant au
moins nous on est en sécurité ma famille
est en sécurité je vois pas
les inquiétudes j'ai pas eu le temps
beaucoup de parler aux gens aujourd'hui
bien sûr le fait d'évacuer parce que
vous savez pas non plus pour combien de
temps l'évacuation sera ordonnée ça peut
être quelques jours et un peu plus long
mais on a confiance que la pluie qui est
annoncée mardi va aider beaucoup les
événements d'ici là on prend pour acquis
qu'on est à l'hôtel pour à peu près 4
jours mais ce qui est rassurant c'est de
savoir que comme chirurgienne comme
médecin vous êtes sur place et que les
gens acceptent-ils pour être bien soigné
effectivement tout le monde merci
beaucoup docteur l'espérance au plaisir
merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]